well their dumplings have been described
as small miracles and now you can find
them on the strip arya's newest
restaurant dintai fun celebrating its
grand opening today
rocky theist joins us live with a taste
of taiwan hi rocky
hey kirsten yes we are celebrating the
grand opening and actually the doors
just opened so congratulations everybody
in here um people are just coming in we
see a couple families
some kids looking at the kitchen because
you know the chefs are back there
working and i'm here with one of the
chefs james
congratulations thank you so much for
calling everyone support
let's let's talk about the food because
first and foremost i smell it
and second it is world famous yes so
we're introducing two of our most
special items or more signature items
popular items
our srimanpur wonton spicy sauce over
here and also our poor shalombe that's
our signature now i hear when you open
this some steam's supposed to come out
it was just a little okay
now i'm not as scared i was afraid i
would have to move away you know to save
the hair
because a lot of steam usually comes out
right exactly and then i just want to go
over really
brief introduction or a description of
our spicy wonton they are made our
may i have all you taught of course
before that we have to give a really
good stir
so everything turns red that's the sign
or visual cue when it's ready to enjoy
okay visual cue also indicates to me
that it is ready now
yeah you will actually get the flavor of
it really quick so it looks really spicy
however it's actually not it gives you a
mild 10g and then a little
sweet texture it's actually yummy i've
been having this dish for the past 10
years
i have never get tired of it it's
delicious and then this is our first
ball the soup dumplings and these are
full of soup
yes they're don't playing with soup and
cyan then are the magic our 18 fold and
then with special soup that we
uh hold it then yes okay so there's a
technique to this yes
but you can enjoy it first and then i'll
bring it okay
it's really soupy is it so hot
it's really perfect yes it's perfect
time perfect timing but so usually we
and
uh we asked our guests to uh enjoy the
soup first by cooking a hole
to hold the dumpling on the spoons first
and then so we can drink the soup from
it first and then
we can have some ginger on top of
dumpling with a flavor infused i love
that and then we can enjoy the whole
dumpling
it's not just you know a restaurant it's
an experience so i know our camera's
looking at the kitchen right now just
really quick what makes the perfect
dumpling the perfect dumpling couple
time definitely we have invest on our
trainings and skills but
all the dumplings are measured by weight
and then by
folds so every single dumplings are away
around 21 grams that's our perfect ratio
and then we also require all the
dumpling has 18 fold
and then they have to be steamed in a
certain time so it's not
over steam or right undercooked
perfect everything is time controlled
exactly you guys have to come down and
enjoy this
grand opening two days the doors just
open reservations are booked all week
but they are taking walk-ins so
take your chance i'll send it back to
you guys
bring home some trays rocky or home to
the station
looks fantastic oh you're making me
hungry rocky all right
thank you my dear